check this out I made a modern version
of the hidden blades from Assassin's
Creed it's time for the ultimate test to
determine if these hidden blades are
truly effect these three goo tubes
represent critical areas and assassin
might Target it's a net
will it slice go
yeah
instead of being spring powered this
time they run on a computer-controlled
CO2 system which gives me control of the
extension speed while still being
extremely powerful and super silent but
the system for this inside of a backpack
so that it's really stealthy and then
the blades are attached to my arm with
foam padded aluminum page and then to
extend and retract the blade all I have
to do is press one button that's hidden
inside of a ring making these very easy
to use and also the world's most
powerful hidden blades stabbing begin
ah